thank you
[Music]
Maury Povich is launching a product Oh
wait Maury Povich from the Mori boat oh
can I guess yes you can okay is it a
paternity test kit it is
one for one
wait you are not the father it's not
that's really good though
guaranteed you're not the father
guaranteed
a question mark
Master brand name look at that what
about um we have genius in the room um
baby daddy and me you don't remember
what he always said when he's holding
the card
and he's like look at the audience he's
like
and the results are in oh my God
damn that's genius that's smart he's 84
years old by the way so he's partnering
with the same DNA testing long overdue
it is he's partnering with the same DNA
Testing Lab he used during the run of
the show and yeah it's called the
results are in
and um cool it's it's gonna help you
settle your paternity disputes you know
what makes me sad is like the evolution
of the talk show like how it used to be
and then like it just ended up being
like Jerry Springer and like like just
Steve Wilkos it's the same thing over
and over it's like paternity test or
whatever right but before they used to
have so much variety it was like it was
like 600 pound people yeah and in their
lives right my husband is a Clans member
yeah
Clans man with like a
uh
and then they would bring them
and he's like what what yeah I don't
give a [__]
and they're blurred yeah editor can you
blur you mean like when it was real
yeah like Jenny Jones remember her like
Sally Jesse I mean like Oprah's OG stuff
but you know what's funny he's Oprah
flipped she was trash she was Springer
in the beginning and then became she
became more serious yeah so funny she's
like a gay klansman and then and then
the gay Clans will come and he's like I
don't give a [__]
yeah
it's so good dude but that's how she
started and then she became like softy
more serious yeah they would start fist
fighting they'd bring up posing yeah and
then the bouncer would come in and
Tackle him but he wanted to see fights
after him yeah that's true but that's
what happens when you go viral right
like you have a viral thing and then it
was like let's get the sequel of that
you become the recommended like the
thing yeah yeah look at Mr Beast dude
yeah and last person to touch this
[__] thing wins every single video do
you think you think his stuff is going
down
it's like a game show like his format
works it works so well it's like
Jeopardy or whatever like years until he
starts bringing in Clans member to fight
like other people dude which one of them
goes insane like it's a billion views
yeah that's all he'll do last last class
member to uh renounce racism
[Laughter]
they would have like relationships where
it's like a little person and a hot girl
yeah and I don't like they don't believe
our relationship you know we're just in
love but I have a confession
don't judge me don't judge it definitely
it definitely started to just be an act
after so and there's always like a group
of teenage girls that are like you're
just jealous flash their tits real quick
for no reason at all yeah like why are
you flashing your tests it's pretty
metal dude I miss those you missed those
I really miss those did they not take a
different form somewhere else like they
couldn't have just yeah I mean a lot of
it's on YouTube now I think we just
don't have TV I mean are they on TV
they're probably still there's probably
but like I think the second generation
of that was like Dr Phil right yeah yeah
and then like Dr Oz was like the Next
Generation Wendy Williams right yeah
yeah or or that's real or the real
[__] or or the view you don't watch
The View it's not the same not the same
because the catch me outside girl I mean
that's always you know like my unruly
teen like that's been around since the
90s right it's usually a white girl that
thinks she's black that has braids and
she goes you're not my parent you can't
judge me they always say the same
they've been saying the same shits as
the knives yeah dialogues you don't know
me you know my favorite was was those
guys that it's like um they're they're
always in like a circular like audience
and they're in like a stage in the
middle and they're like they're doing
readings of like oh like um I'm getting
someone's grandmother that passed
recently John Edward yeah yeah that's
almost like it's like I'm getting well
the first letter j j wait anywhere in
the room
they need to bring those back yeah
because that was good [__] really good
[__] because you're just curious to see
like where is he gonna go and then like
John Edward they remember they did that
opening with him and he's like I'm John
Edward and since I was young I knew it
was different and they're like do a 360
because the Matrix just came out so you
do like a 360 around him like being
still and [__] and like his psychic mind
is activated those are banging remember
when the talk shows used to bring on the
obese people to talk they would even
show how they broke down the wall to get
them out with the forklift yeah and then
they flew him to the studio yeah yeah I
mean they still have my 600 pound life
that's pretty in-depth yeah that's true
oh remember there was a phase where
ladies would just do like a bunch of
drugs to be able to have like 10 kids
yep oh like Octomom yeah because because
of John and Kate Plus
John Kate plus eight
and they were and that was like such a
monetizable show that everybody was like
oh my God I love them and then he flew
up the handle right yeah because they're
not even together anymore you know
what's funny a clip popped up on my
Instagram feed and it was like like say
I'm Kate and you're John and we're
sitting down and she's like can you stop
breathing like that you it's really
[__]
and you're just like oh my God no wonder
they didn't work out yeah a little
warning signs yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
seen that before okay Jessica that show
Jessica Simpson yeah Nick Lachey yeah
dude she's like art like she said like
the chicken of the sea yeah yeah what
was the chicken it was the tuna yeah
yeah
but it was a whole thing they're just
trolling the whole she was doing the
whole um she was doing the parasailing
bit yeah some people still don't know
yeah good for her people don't know
parasails whole [__] personality is a
bit it's pretty crazy they killed it too
they monetized the [__] out of it
because they had their own TV show too
right where they would like be Farmers
or some [__] simple life Nicole Richie
and her yeah
but remember like um like Jessica
Simpson right now is a billionaire
billionaire billionaire with a bee wow
is it because of products or Fox
Clothing oh wow whole line whatever
what's her line called
Simpsons
that's good at J by Simpson yeah I don't
know
one of my favorite uh formats for one of
those shows is like the geek to Chic
segments when they did geeked it like
you would see the past and then like
they're like super hot now and then like
they bring someone for their past of
like their crush and then like wait do
you guys remember this really old show
me Jessica Simpson's Gold line is called
because you were so good at Brandon
earlier so you asked me his questions I
can't think like a woman you'll get this
one though no it's like one of their
songs I bet we all get it out of the
millions of words that exist yes
Jessica
Simpson
[Laughter]
oh do you guys remember this is gonna be
like kind of a deep cut because I think
it was like only like a brief moment but
it was like Beauty and the Geeks and
Beauties Beauty And The Geek yeah
whereas like that show where it's like
this competition game right pair like
Beauties with geeks yep
um interesting together for sure dude no
but it was it was like they would go
through these different challenges
Bachelor kind of oh there's like a nerd
it's like love Island
kind of but like I'm trying to remember
like the premise of like the challenges
though too like like getting them to get
out of their own shell and no was that
what it was like challenges that would
be
um like a little more tailored towards
like yeah like dorks the Geeks like the
Beauties would have to try academic
subjects and the guys are challenged and
physical yeah because I think I remember
them trying to pick up girls the Geeks
pretty good we're like trying to get
phone numbers
in this day and age you'll just be
considered bullying or something bro
have you seen that remember they just
have a pickup artist show yeah with
mystery [__] was crazy awful you're just
like oh but it came at it came at an age
where we didn't know if it was legit or
not yeah we're like does it work no of
course you gotta tackle a set and it was
like a bunch of people as soon as yeah
check yet you're so vulnerable to all
that [__] you're like you're gonna be
this [__] what's up I gotta do that oh
and there was another show called
um
it was like the swan or something oh
yeah yeah the girls would get plastic
surgery they'd be like I think they
probably done enough but they'd be total
Algos and then like go through plastic
surgery and then they'd give them a
reveal and they look at themselves in
the mirror they go
oh my God that's so beautiful
that's crazy that's so that cheese is
the right thing yeah to young girls I
feel like we've talked about this on
here maybe maybe no everything sounds
like deja vu sometimes you know did you
know that like a lot of La chicks get
plastic surgery I didn't really know
that until like two years ago Dude I
should I feel like that's the standard
yeah one of my homies is a nurse she's
an attestation type of thing yes
estheticians things
oh she's anesthetist
uh your dad your hero didn't teach you
how to talk
anesthesiologist no no she does like the
the beauty stuff okay estheticians yeah
what did I say earlier an equestrian
she's in a question
no she's a nurse she's a nurse you gotta
be a nurse to do that [__] are you sure
you don't need to you do yeah she got
you can eat an RN though like a legit
she got a legit degree
no no no I think depending on how far
you want to go the higher and you think
they go to school for that
so what about this [__] but but she was
so what about this no but she be
my friend tell me about this business
you realize how many people of all kinds
oh yeah yeah yeah in La whether it's
moms you know supermodels or just normal
folks they spend all their money doing
that yeah yeah my uncle is a doctor a
plastic surgeon and he'll [__] with uh
my aunt she gets Botox done by him oh
sorry she [__] it up all the time on
purpose just to mess with her no
because like but she's not gonna pay
anywhere else no but like it's it's all
temporary yeah but he'll like do it to
like he'll do it uneven just to [__]
with her and she'll be like
oh my God and like it just goes back are
they siblings depending on how you put
what are these siblings my uncle and
Aunt oh husband are married yeah okay
no they're not so her face is lopsided
for like 20 days he's Filipino and she's
British
you just get it done all the time yeah
so then you can just mix it you do
little doses here and there to like
he'll [__] with her eyebrows so it's
like this God damn it
[Music]
oh